so we had an obviously incredible week
for the LGBT community and their allies
we don't wanna forget about the allies
love the allies yes the Supreme Court
finally did the right thing so this
national endless debate over states
rights and can you get married here and
divorced there and if you get married
here does it count they're all that it
is gone we are all going to be treated
equally under the law
which is all gay people wanted right gay
people didn't want extra rights or bonus
rights just equality under the law which
now gay people have and I think it is
absolutely great of course now there's
some states in the south where people
are fighting giving licenses and all
that and of course it never really ends
the the battle for equality never ends
not just for gay rights and for black
people but for everybody the battle for
equality is this endless thing that
keeps going but this was a major major
step in the right direction right but I
wanted to bring up something that I saw
this week in Turkey so this past weekend
in Istanbul in Turkey they had their gay
pride parade now Turkey is thought of as
the most Western Muslim country that
there is it is by far the most secular
that the fact that they could even have
a gay parade is pretty fantastic
unfortunately didn't turn out that
fantastic and we've got some video
all right so I wanted to show you that
just to show that the fight for equality
is not over not only in this country but
all over the place and believe me there
are far worse places for gay people than
Turkey of course there are many
countries right there in the Middle East
where you can literally be put to death
and they're hanging people in Iran and
all that stuff for being gay so while
some good things have happened here and
it's really great we got to take a
moment to embrace that and see that
actual change is happening here that
it's not done and it's not done in the
rest of the world and let's keep an eye
on it and and hope that it gets better